bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la chine dans le piège
du zéro co vide à shanghai les 27
millions d'habitants vit bhl martyrs
épuisé nerveusement la part un
confinement qui tourne à la
séquestration depuis plus d'un mois la
colère monte un soulèvement est il
possible dans le pays contre la méthode
forte de shipping quel sera le prix de
cette dictature sanitaires sur la chine
mais aussi sur notre économie on en
parle dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau notre grand témoin ce
soit va nous éclairer sur la hausse des
prix c'est la valse des étiquettes au
supermarché plus 10 à 15 % sur les
produits de première nécessité jusqu'où
va grimper l'inflation la banque
fédérale américaine pourrait opérer un
virage majeur ce soir en augmentant ses
taux directeurs nous en parlerons avec
l'économiste jean marc daniel avec nous
ce soir enfin nous retrouverons nos a
franchi pour la leur parti-pris la météo
des législatives avec l amour d'un gamin
qui revient largement ce soir sur
l'accord conclu entre le ps et les
insoumis richard wehrli s'interroge sur
l'europe sociale version mélenchon et la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand s'est
penché sur le mot de la semaine la
radicalité vous l'aurez deviné voilà
pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous bonsoir jean marc daniel
bonsoir très heureuse de vous recevoir
dans ce fauteuil du grand témoin
économiste professeur à l'ehess cp vous
allez nous éclairer tout à l'heure sur
la hausse des prix cette inflation qui
pourrait atteindre des niveaux records
on parle de 10% tant dans quelques mois
un niveau record bien sûr sous le coup
de la crise énergétique et de la guerre
en ukraine on va en parler on attend la
décision de la banque fédérale
américaine ce soir mais on va commencer
avec ce qui se passe en chine et cette
politique du zéro co vide quoi qu'il en
coûte
voilà shanghai la capitale économique du
pays c'était il ya quelques jours où la
population crie son désespoir d'être
confiné on en parle avec vous ce soir
françoise nicolas bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau grande spécialiste de la
chine vous dirigez de centre asie de
l'ifri l'institut français des relations
internationales
bonsoir michel bonnin merci à vous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
aussi grand spécialiste de la chine
sinologue à le sss renaud piarroux va
nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
vous le savez les spécialistes des
maladies infectieuses il est souvent
venu sur ce plateau au chef de service à
la pitié salpêtrière il nous dira
pourquoi cette politique du zéro co vide
et celle qu'a choisi la chine enfin bon
soir simon le plâtre et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous depuis shanghai où will
et tard je crois une heure du matin 1h30
même vous êtes le correspondant du monde
à shanghai sur place où nous dire
exactement ce que vous vivez et ce que
vivent les habitants après plus d'un
mois maintenant de confinement
extrêmement strictes mais on va
commencer avec les images qui nous
parviennent de shanghai est d'ailleurs
en chine avec et grâce aux réseaux
sociaux avec vous ce soir si j'ai bien
compris stéphane blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir et réame bon
soir à toutes et à tous si j'ai bien
compris ce soir ben si j'ai bien compris
et myriam ya 345 millions de chinois qui
aujourd'hui n'ont plus le droit de
sortir de chez eux et forcément ça
commence à créer des tensions donc
évidemment on chine sait pas exactement
comme chez nous s'il vous prend l'envié
de manifester contre la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement mieux vaut ne
pas les place tiananmen il y en a qui
ont essayé c'est en 89 et je crois que
ça a marqué un peu tout le monde donc
aujourd'hui on a vu de france contenter
de faire du bruit des casseroles la nuit
pour pas être repéré par la police en
fait alors ça fait un mois maintenant un
peu plus d'un mois il ya un risque
d'explosion sociale sur place demander
ça à nos spécialistes c'est pour moi qui
vais me prononcer mais on voit bien que
la rigueur du confinement forcément ça
crée une grosse grosse pression
psychologique sur tout le monde en avait
une il doit ses cheveux contre l'autre
jour un français expatrié qui cherche
absolument à sortir pour assister aux
obsèques de son frère en france vous
avez la police chinoise s'est pas montré
de très très compréhensive
[Musique]
tu vis en chine tu dois respecter la loi
chinoise
tu le sais non
rires je vais mourir
donc soit sûr c'était vraiment un gros
coup de pression psychologique il va
mieux tf1 qui était abandonnée on voit
comment la police réagit et comment les
gens se montrent à quel point la
répression est extrêmement sévère on ne
se refait pas enfin jean ping comme
l'héritier d'un autre s'étonne je vous
rappelle que pendant la révolution
culturelle quelque chose qui était très
prisé c'était les chances d'autocritique
on devait avouer les ennemis du peuple
bien avouer leurs fautes publiquement
pourquoi on reste le même principe sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le peuple lui-même
qui doit donc avouer ses fautes devant
la police notamment quand on est en
train de confinement
il
[Musique]
encore là c'est un humiliant même si
c'est extrêmement grave en chine de
perdre la face mais la stratégie zéro co
vite ça consiste au bas-saint-laurent
fermés les gens sont chez eux ce fossile
et dépister les tester donc si quelqu'un
est testée positive on doit l'envoyer
dans un camp d'isolement dont je vous
montre des images qui peuvent les voir
au départ par être amusante parce qu'en
fait aux miens que les vêtements sont
pas la taille de ce petit bonhomme là où
c'est pas du tout drôle c'est quand on
comprend qu'en fait c'est un enfant qui
a été testé positif est qu'on
l'éloignent du foyer de ses parents donc
voyez bien qu'il a évidemment pas envie
d'y aller le pauvre que ça devient
carrément déchirant mais voilà jusqu'où
à la rigueur du du confinement et de l'
isolement qui a lié la stratégie zéro
que vides en fait et donc même lorsqu'un
enfant est positif il voit quitter le
foyer ça exactement donc puis je vais
vous dire que parler secrète bouclé les
services sanitaires frappe à votre porte
mais portent pas forcément envie
d'ouvrir
vous allez voir comment ça se passe en
fait c'est la dame elle sent bien que
finalement ça ferait mieux que nous
devons pas on négocie un peu mais vous
allez voir que ils sont très très
insistants et quand il frappe à votre
porte c'est vraiment très très fort et
l'inspection sanitaire voilà comment ça
ça peut finir
tout ça c'est le
recul sur des réseaux sociaux ou de jean
réussi à filmer donc quelques vidéos
s'échappe mais on ouvre on comprend un
peu comment fait la police investi de
tous les pans de la vie privée des
déchets non ça c'est l'illustration par
l'image du zéro corrida c'est à dire oui
au départ la truck du siroco vis de la
politique aujourd'hui elle marchait pas
trop mal enfin au début il ya même me
regarder dans l'express on disait ah bah
oui quand même la chine elle se félicite
l'europe avait beaucoup plus de mal
d'ailleurs en septembre 2020 xi jingping
donc à organiser une cérémonie pour
remercier les héros qui avait permis la
victoire sont que vides donc ça c'est
les cfc les bains de foule en chine mais
c'est tout pas beaucoup plus calme que
les banques foulée président macron un
peu pas de bousculade
personne ne s'approche du président mini
pas vraiment je compense donc c'était
vraiment une grande fierté voilà pour
d'avoir réussi à vaincre ça sauf qu'avec
le barrio micron qui est beaucoup plus
contagieux cette stratégie aux héroïnes
ne fonctionne pas en australie l'ont
fait et en nouvelle zélande ils l'ont
fait en taiwan en fait ils ont tous
arrêté parce que ça ne marchait pas
alors pourquoi ne pas y renoncer à cette
stratégie 08 alors parce que il n'ya pas
que les imbéciles qui ne changent jamais
d'avis il y a aussi les dictateurs parce
qu'évidemment si jean ping se mettaient
à changer la vie ça veut dire qu'il
pourrait se tromper donc il s'y tromper
une fois est ce qui pourra pas se
tromper sur d'autres sujets est ce que
vraiment le communisme c'est vraiment le
meilleur système politique ça sera pas
le même début de la démocratie ça serait
évidemment une catastrophe pour les
chinois mais là je préfère les pour les
chinois pour le pouvoir en place en
chine donc je préfère laisser parler les
spécialistes merci beaucoup pour ce tour
d'horizon en images de ce qui se passe
en chine grâce aux réseaux sociaux on a
envie de leur dire merci pour une fois
les réseaux sociaux françoise nicolas le
monde entier tombe le masque sauf les
chinois vous qui connaissez le régime de
shipping ça vous surprend
cette méthode forte à à l'aide de drones
on a vu des petits robots si on les
verra peut-être tout à l'heure avec des
haut-parleurs contrôle social complet
numérique de la population passe un cran
la ces nouveaux ou pas non c'est pas si
nouveau que ça en fait c'est ça
s'inscrit exactement dans la lignée du
changement qui est arrivé avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir de saisine pays il a durci
véritablement le régime et c'est une
conséquence ou la poursuite de ceux de
ce durcissement donc c'est pas du tout
surprenant et sur le fait qu' ils ne
reviennent pas sur la décision s'il ne
revient pas sur cette position de sur
cette politique du zéro co vide c'est
extrêmement évident ça voudrait dire que
ce qu'il a érigée comme preuve de la
supériorité du régime chez loin et du
système chinois étaient faux donc ça
c'est juste impossible ce serait perdre
la face et ça c'est absolument
inconcevable parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que cette politique du zéro
co vide qui effectivement a marché dans
un premier temps elle a été montrée
comme étant la preuve que en chine on
savait gérer la crise alors que les
démocraties occidentales complètement
désorganisée et n'était absolument pas à
même de s'attaquer à un tel problème
donc là c'était vraiment la preuve de la
supériorité michel bonnin
on a l'impression que on est quand même
face à une surveillance généralisée
technologique j'ai montré le petit robot
parce qu' il n'était pas dans le papier
de de stéphane on va le voir est ce
qu'on l'a à l'image c'est un petit robot
qui voit la surveille avec un
haut-parleur sur le dos et qui se balade
comme ça dans tous shanghai en a
plusieurs d'ailleurs
ça au fond qu'est-ce que ça signifie
c'est qu'il est prêt à tout sea shipping
aujourd'hui pour séquestrer son peuple
en fait habile il est prêt à tout pour
contrôler son peuple contrôler son
peuple et contrôler le pouvoir par la
même occasion donc ça c'est et c'est la
transformation du système qui a toujours
existé du totalitarisme maoïste en
système inspiré de 1984 année du charme
et de la date du contrôle de science
fiction qui n'est plus de la
science-fiction maintenant c'est la
réalité on peut contrôler d'une façon
absolument extraordinaire et il a ce
qu'on voit là elles réussissent à passer
quelques parents c'est que les réseaux
sociaux est extrêmement surveiller
contrôler voire carrément interdit ça ça
lui fait perdre un peu la face parce que
on voit que les autorités diplomatiques
chinoises commencent à essayer de
contrecarrer des critiques le monde
entier s'offusque de voir ça oui ça
c'est effectivement le il ne peut pas
totalement
contrôlé les réseaux sociaux mais ce que
vous voyez là ce qu'on a vu çà a été
enregistrée maintenant si vous voulez
aller sur le même site il n'est plus là
c'est sûr qu'il n'est plus là vous
comprenez c'est b il ya forcément un
temps de retard dans la plupart des cas
et donc donc il ya l'information quand
même s'ils reculent un peu dans toute la
chine pour ceux qui veulent l'entendre
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est un problème
mais
votre question au départ était est ce
que ça peut amener à un soulèvement à
l'est de la copulation là c'est autre
chose en taille donc donc voilà mais je
pense que je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit françois nicolas
l'essentiel c'est que sit-in ping ne
peut pas reconnaître qu'il a qu'il a eu
tort puisque de toute façon s'il avait
fait de ce de ce succès
contre le coc vide après houran le la
preuve de la supériorité du socialisme
et de de son socialisme à lui bonsoir
renaud piarroux bonsoir merci d'être là
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses
pl clp triaire officiellement il n'y a
pas plus d'une cinquantaine de morts par
jour en chine et à peine plus de trois
mille cartes donc c'est beaucoup moins
qu'en france est ce qu'on peut croire
déjà ces chiffres
j'ai pas d'idée si on peut les croire ou
pas mais de toute façon on est au tout
début d'une flambée donc les morts
arrivent un peu tardivement mais omicron
omicron les morts arrivent un peu
tardivement donc déjà de toutes façons
de par la structure d'une épidémie il
faut surtout pas se reposer sur ce petit
nombre de morts par jour c'est quelque
chose de différent l'enjeu en fait
si j'ai bien compris la population
chinoise est pas très bien vaccinés et
en particulier les personnes les plus
âgées
les vaccins sont pas les plus
performants
voilà il y a plusieurs vaccins chinois
en plus mais ils n'ont pas les mêmes
outils de sortie du zéro co vide que
d'autres pays en asie ou en océanie
l'australie la nouvelle zélande
stratégie dans laquelle sans tête 2-0
vide c'est jiping qui peut faire
autrement concernant considérant que les
personnes âgées ne sont pas tous
vaccinés on sait qu'il ya 40 % des plus
de 60 ans qui ne sont pas en chine et
que si j'ai bien lu pour préparer cette
émission les différents papiers qu'on
peut avoir dans la presse le système de
soins intensifs n'est pas optimal en
chine ils peuvent tout à fait se
trouvait débordés si l' on s'en est
sorti pas si facilement que ça sur la
vague ou micron puisqu'on a eu jusqu'à
30 ils personnes hospitalisées
simultanément en france te dire là le
même niveau d'hospitalisation pas pour
les réanimations mais pour les
hospitalisations le même niveau que ce
qu'on balaye sur les vagues précédentes
mais non seulement on était quand même
pratiquement tous immunisés vacciner et
il y avait eu plusieurs aux vagues et
beaucoup de gens avaient été immunisés
parmi les non vaccinés donc c'est passé
en australie en nouvelle zélande ils ont
vraiment forcer sur la vaccination et
s'est passé mais sans la un bon vaccin
est sans une population et couvertures
vaccinales très importante la chine est
au devant d'un vrai problème si elle
laisse filer le virus dont vous nous
dites scientifiques se voit là il ya une
impasse il ya une impasse sanitaires
alors on va rester un instant sur ce que
vivent la population je vous redonner la
parole je vous promets mais je vais vous
montrer ce petit reportage kathia gilder
a pu rencontrer à un français à shanghai
vous l'avez compris les français sont
comme les chinois sur place soumis aux
mêmes confinement très strictes il est
confiné depuis cinquante trois jours
dans sa résidence regardez puis ensuite
on part à shanghai avec un simon le
plâtre jusqu'à pas juste après
voilà à quoi ressemble le quotidien de
thomas emmuré avec ses voisins dans le
quartier universitaire de l'utah ce
professeur de français expatriés en
chine depuis dix ans en est à son 53e
jours de confinement vous pensez
vraiment aux jo jour aujourd'hui à voir
ce qui va se passer est ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui ce qu'on va manger
enfin c'est vraiment des dépenses à très
court terme une pas trop penser à sortir
ce que sinon on devient vraiment
malheureux en fait cours en ligne jeux
de société et même fête d'anniversaire
pour thomas la vie continue un semblant
de vie sociale maintenu grâce à internet
que des apéros quiz avec les amis tous
les deux trois jours mais c'était mon
anniversaire ya quelques temps donc
voilà j'ai essayé de faire un live a
live sur les réseaux sociaux pour donner
un peu un aspect de fête concombres
carottes oignons tomates laitues des
épinards je crois la priorité numéro un
quand on est confiné cessé de
s'alimenter les repas sont spartiates
mais le système d fonctionne on a eu des
pommes et des oranges mais pas de
légumes donc heureusement j'en ai reçu
demain la cité parce que sinon je sais
pas comment je ferais on a eu beaucoup
aussi de chou et de et de laitue qui
sont des aliments bah oui mais surtout
que ça ne nourrit pas tellement en fait
les biens de première nécessité sont eux
aussi rationner donc du savon kleenex
shampooings dentifrices donc ça veut
dire que mon avis on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge et que les kleenex et ceux du
procureur et 2500 personnes habitent ici
particularité en chine c'est le comité
de quartier qui gère la vie dans la
résidence il s'occupe de la nourriture
des tests pcr mais aussi de la police
les habitants sont libres de circuler
entre les îlots mais interdits de
quitter la résidence mais je peux sortir
pour sortir les poubelles par exemple
après pour sortir doit la résidence d'un
possible parce qu'il ya des gardes et
avec une grille aux forêts le jeu je
force le passage de façon violente mais
c'est pas évident en sortant de la
résidence thomas prendrait le risque
d'être contaminé et de se retrouver dans
un camp en périphérie de shanghai sort
réservé aux personnes positives il reste
donc chez lui sans avoir aucune idée de
sa date de libération
simon le plâtre vous qui êtes à shanghai
depuis depuis la france on a
l'impression qu'on fout le régime est en
train de rendre un peu dingue la
population pardonnez moi l'expression
est ce que c'est ce qui se passe comment
les gens font pour tenir tout simplement
je pense que la plupart des gens à
shanghai et prennent leur mal en
patience mais effectivement c'est de
plus en plus pénible et c'est pour ça
que vous vous montriez dans certaines
images à des gens qui crient depuis
leurs fenêtres il ya des gens qui n'en
peuvent plus
après les situations sont assez
aléatoires
parce que il ya des résidences ils sont
mieux traités que d'autres mais
organisés que d'autres d'où voilà
certaines personnes résidant dans tout
ça explose eu des conflits de plus
violent plus dans le sujet on a vu dans
le sujet qui a décollé de cartes un
pardon non c'est moi qui vous découpez
pardonnez moi on a vu dans le sujet qui
avait des comités de quartier qui
quadrillaient la ville est-ce que là
nourriture est rationnée est ce que les
gens enfin qu'est ce qui se passe de ce
point de vue là sur place
justement je pense que c'est ce côté
très aléatoire qui est frustrant et qui
rend aussi assez difficile de se faire
une idée claire de la situation c'est
que selon les districts et même selon
les quartiers les comités de quartier eh
bien on va avoir une situation très
différente il faut rappeler quand même
que la partie est de la ville pudding
ils n'ont eu que quelques heures pour se
préparer à ce confinement il ya des gens
qui m'aiment était déjà continué depuis
des semaines au moment où le confinement
a été annoncée moi je suis sur la partie
ouest j'ai pu faire mes courses un peu
plus de la vence mais beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas pu se préparer donc ça a créé
des situations assez difficile il ya
aussi beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
forcément équipés pour faire la cuisine
qui se sont retrouvés confiné au bureau
au travail dans une usine break dont il
ya eu plein de situations différentes et
puis plus de confinement dur plus sacré
ban et des problèmes les gens arrivent
au bout de leurs provisions se retrouve
à manger du riz blanc donc voilà il y a
eu des gens qui sont beaucoup plaints de
leur situation je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de gens qui soit tout
simplement mort de femmes ayant
notamment des personnes âgées on a vu
sortir
ne pas respecter le confinement et et se
faire pourrait demander par la police
parce que tout simplement ils n'avaient
plus rien à manger or en ce moment à
part les distributions du gouvernement
qui comme tu ton très aléatoire selon
les quartiers vous ne pouvez que
commander en ligne par des commandes
groupées donc si vous pensez à toutes
les personnes âgées qui ne sont pas très
difficiles et dans ces centres de
quarantaine que s'y passe-t-il pour les
personnes testées positives est ce qu on
le sait
oui beaucoup de gens ils sont allés
quelques français mais surtout beaucoup
de chinois
en gros les conditions sont vraiment
très spartiate c'est une des ligues
d'élite camps qui sont installés dans le
meilleur des cas il ya des cloisons qui
sépare ces lignes mais en gros c'est
comme un open space géant avec des
milliers de lits des sanitaires vraiment
attrait et sordide plusieurs personnes
m'ont dit il n'y a pas d'eau courante
dans la plupart de ces centres donc une
jeune fille me disait qu'elle
remplissait des bastides pour tirer la
chasse en gros à l'aps une source d'eau
potable et puis les lumières qui restent
allumées toute la nuit on voit des trucs
qui paraissent assez hallucinant
le clairement le but c'est simplement
d'isoler les gens du reste de la société
c'est pas d'avoir des bonnes conditions
pour se reposer et se remettre du coc
vite et on a l'impression que le régime
s'enfonce quand même dans une impasse de
plus en plus impopulaire on a vu des des
moments de deux manifestations de colère
dans la population qui même se mettaient
à crier sur la police est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur l'ampleur
du mécontentement sur place
je pense qu'à shanghai le mécontentement
est fort et largement partagée
de là à ce que ça devienne un vrai
mouvement social c'est compliqué puisque
d'abord les gens sont confinés chez eux
donc les gens sont extrêmement divisée
donc ce qu'on a vu c'est plutôt des
petits mouvements sociaux ce pour a dit
que c'est à dire sur un cas précis
un manque de nourriture ou un
bâtiment entier qui devait être emporté
quelque part là on peut avoir une fille
concret avec la police mais dans la
plupart des cas les gens sont simplement
frustré et restent chez eux et peuvent
éventuellement faire part de leur
frustration sur les réseaux sociaux et
ensuite ce qu'il faut rappeler aussi
c'est que hors de shanghai dans le reste
de la chine une grande partie des
gérants d'une part ne sont pas vraiment
au courant de la situation réelle à
shanghai s'ils sont pas très connectée
s'ils se contentent de regarder la
télévision par exemple ils peuvent avoir
l'impression que ça se passe pas
spécialement mal et puis d'ailleurs il
ya eu des confinement ailleurs en chine
et donc moi j'ai demandé à des gens qui
ne sont pas à shanghai est en fait la
plupart des gens continuent à se tenir
le 0 koffi il ya même un peu un côté bon
à shanghai ont essayé de ne pas se
confiner donc finalement c'est un peu
bien fait pour shanghai le brix shanghai
c'est un peu paris pour la chine ce
faire la ville un peu plus plus riches
essaye de faire les choses mieux donc
voilà il ya un soutien
très pessimiste sur les chances d'un
véritable soulèvement interne à la
population merci infiniment merci simon
le plat d'être voilà venue témoigner
depuis shanghai et bon courage pour
votre travail confiné bien évidemment on
imagine merci à vous c'est naïf
d'imaginer un soulèvement françoise
nicolas je crains que ce soit un peu
naïf oui parce qu'il ya des mains des
moyens de répression qui sont telles que
si d'aventuré il ya un soulèvement il
sera assez vite réprimés mais en plus
jusqu'à présent ce que l'on voit
effectivement je pense que simon le
plâtre avait raison on voit des
manifestations de mécontentement est
complètement isolé pour qu'il ya un vrai
soulèvement pour qu'il y ait une
tentative de renversement du pouvoir par
exemple il faudrait qu'il y ait une
coordination dont il faudrait vraiment
que les gens puissent s'organiser or ça
n'est absolument pas le cas pour
l'instant et si d'aventuré il tentait de
le faire je pense que le pouvoir en
place serait assez prompts à les
encourager évidemment des parallèles
avec ce qui se passe en russie la
propagande est puissante les gens
soutiennent cette politique
véritablement sur place le zéro co vide
est licite et
beaucoup de gens ont peur entre pairs du
coc ville parce qu'on leur ils ont ils
ont vu ils ont eu très peur au moment de
buran quand on a eu le premier que vides
la banque tout le monde avait peur nous
aussi je n'en avais rien qu'on n'avait
rien pour lutter contre et donc donc ils
sont restés et comme comme il ya eu
cette politique du zéro que vides et
comme n'y a pas eu de l'internet 500
efficace
ils en sont restés là ils en sont restés
à cette peur du coc libre et voilà mais
c'est à dire quand même c'est que ce qui
est incroyable c'est que le gouvernement
chinois mais pas protéger sa population
en achetant des bébés vaccin à pizza on
voit moderna c'est ça qui est incroyable
c'est elle perdre la face là où est ce
qui est assez incroyable c'est que au
contraire y maintient la politique zéro
co vide au nom de la défense de la
population c'est ça qui est un croyant
alors que c'est absolument pas le cain
mais en fait c'est par orgueil national
et aussi pour prouver la supériorité
justement du modèle chinois qui peuvent
pas acheter des vaccins étrangers c'est
ces foyers fermés dans cette logique de
pierrot le vaccin chinois c'est pas un
vaccin arn messagers weiser au modern
art c'est un vaccin classique mais moins
protecteur moins efficace pour les uns
il ya plusieurs vaccins mais
effectivement ils sont ils sont plutôt
moins protecteur donc on en attend pas
grand chose il ya eu d'autres pays je
crois que c'est le pérou qui avaient été
vaccinés comme ça et qu'il ya eu ou le
chili ou le pérou qui est quand même une
vague épidémique derrière il faut savoir
qu on al impression qu micron est moins
dangereux il est moins dangereux que le
delta il est à peu près aussi dangereux
que la première souche donc ce qui pend
au nez des chinois c'est d'avoir une
diffusion extrêmement rapide si si la
schl à un scénario type hong kong c'est
ça voilà
papa d'un passage extrêmement rapide
mais hong kong à la taille chinoise donc
dacia vous imaginez
1400 millions habitants et avec un virus
qui reste quand même dangereux il a été
moins en france parce que nous étions
immunisés et ne le sont pas ou ne sont
beaucoup moins donc s'ils ont beaucoup
plus à risque c'est une population qui
est plutôt plus vieilles et donc
c'est l'erreur c'était pas forcément le
zéro co vide c'est ce qui a permis à
l'australie à beaucoup de pays d'asile
et c'est d'avoir une mortalité
c'est la manière de sortir du siroco
viallard fois que ça ne pouvait pas le
savoir qu'on allait avoir quelque chose
comme 1 micron qui est extrêmement
contagieux un comptage et on va regarder
la carte ya deux villes qui ont été
confinés strictement c'est shanghai et
shenzhen qui est au sud à côté de hong
kong et puis à deux autres villes qui
ont un tour de vis supplémentaire avec
des renforcements de restriction c'est
la capitale pékin et ding dessous qui
dans le centre du pays compte tenu de
tout ce que vous nous avez dit renaud
piarroux on n'en sort jamais ou chine en
fait comment ils vont faire
et risque fort d'avoir une grosse
épidémie qui va arriver soit ils
arrivent avec le zéro co vide et ils
sont obligés de maintenir avec peut-être
un peu moins de cas autour de la chine
donc moins de cas importés
soit ils arrivent à tenir c'est
peut-être ça ce qu'ils espèrent soit il
lâche le truc et ils ont quelque chose
qui va être très compliqué à gérer aussi
au niveau de la population enfin votre
regard parce que merci d'avoir patienté
avec
jean marc daniel oui à mon avis sont
complètement coincé soit ils
maintiennent 0 coheed et il bloque
l'économie pour l'instant c'est quand
même ce qui se passe rien of ya un choc
de demande enfin l'économie complètement
bloquée comme ça c'est quand même pas
une voix particulièrement encourageantes
soit ils h et effectivement comme ils
n'ont pas préparé les conditions pour la
sortie du zéro covin il se retrouve avec
une épidémie qui va flamber avec un
système hospitalier qui apparemment
n'est pas exactement au niveau voulu
avec une population effectivement en
partie la partie de la population la
plus vulnérable qui n'est pas avec ciné
et donc c'est aussi la catastrophe donc
quoi qu'il arrive de toute façon les
deux voies sont assez peu encourageantes
elle va être le prix de cette dictature
sanitaires alors je pense que ce sera
d'autant plus lourd à payer que
l'économie chinoise avant déjà donné
signes d'essoufflement c'est d'ailleurs
les chinois la reconnaissait même on est
sorti d'une période où on avait des
croissances à deux chiffres aux un taux
de 10% et les derniers rapports du fmi
avant donc dans 2021 nouvelle vague de
l'aco vide annoncé que 5 % ça allait
devenir un objectif quasiment
inaccessible et le premier ministre
chinois le reconnaissait lui-même des 4
% si on arrive à 4 8% se sera bien et la
croissance de long terme on sera
peut-être plutôt aux alentours de 2 et
demi 3 % donc on a une économie qui est
déjà essoufflé on a une économie
effectivement qui a du mal à se
positionner par rapport à des
concurrents qui sont en train d'émerger
la chine est soumise à la pression du
vietnam de l'inde et puis on a aussi un
discours c'est la sphère jacques macé
dire une reprise en main d'un certain
nombre de gens qui avaient été à
l'origine du succès en tant
qu'entrepreneur qui sont accusés d'être
corrompus qui disparaissent
ils font des autocritiques qui est donc
d'aider chaque mois on en retrouvera
plus beaucoup et jacques macé le
fondateur d'alibaba sein des grands nez
symbole de la réussite entrepreneuriale
de la chine et donc voilà le tour de vis
être sur l'économie sur toutes les
entreprises qui pourraient avoir un
esprit critique c'est bien ça oui
étrangères ces deux choses dans le
discours officiel c'est on regrette
l'union soviétique on dit on ne fera
jamais de lire erreurs qui ont été
commises par les communistes soviétiques
on ne cédera pas sur le plan de la
liberté de l'ordre public et la deuxième
chose c'est on commence à avoir un
discours qui consiste à dire les
américains se sont toujours débrouillés
pour avoir un fournisseur pas cher
d'abord ça a été l'allemagne ensuite ça
a été le japon après ça a été la corée
et puis quand ils ont senti qu'on
devenait plus cher up laisser ton change
et l'atelier ou changer d'atelier et
donc le prochain atelier que les
américaines ont en tête c'est
probablement l'aide et les chinois
disent oui mais les allemands et les
japonais ils étaient obligés de se
soumettre vu le passé qu'ils avaient
nous on n'a pas le même passé donc on va
pas se laisser faire et donc il ya tout
un discours en disant on va s'adapter on
va être à l'avant-garde de la des
nouvelles technologies on va être une
puissance en rivalité avec des états
unis et non en fournisseur des états
unis et à court terme les conséquences
par exemple pour l'europe pour nous
français d'un ralentissement de la
croissance chinoise ya aussi toute une
série de chaînes d'approvisionnement qui
sont à l'arrêt a baissé de la deuxième
économie mondiale quand vous arrêtez la
deuxième économie mondiale tout le monde
éternue c'est qu'il n'y a pas de mystère
c'est et est donc effectivement et et en
plus c'est effectivement beaucoup de
pays beaucoup d'eux se disent ça va
créer des raretés donc ça va créer des
pressions sur les prix et les outils
qu'on a traditionnellement ne peuvent
pas fonctionner puisque le seul
véritable élément qui permettrait de
résoudre le problème ce serait que les
chinois se remette à travailler il n'y a
pas de véritable substitution alors là
aussi une sorte de spirale infernale en
fait
économique à tous les niveaux certains
de réflexion qui naissent au niveau des
pays occidentaux consistant à dire
l'erreur ça a été non pas de délocaliser
nos industries mais de la délocaliser
dans un seul pays et donc on s'est
rendus dépendants de ce pays on va
continuer à délocaliser mais elle donc
quand même en indonésie au vietnam et en
afrique françoise nicolas ça ça les
chinois le savent oui les démêlés
dépendance je suis assez d'accord avec
ce qu'il a à dire jean daniel en partie
les dépenses elles ont été créées par
nous mêmes il ya un exemple absolument
au blé matticks et les terres rares les
terres rares contrairement à ce que le
nom indique elles sont pas du tout rare
on peut en trouver ailleurs mais c'était
extrêmement polluant et donc on a
délégué en quelque sorte à la la chine
et on était bien content finalement de
faire produire ses terres rares à la
chine parce que comme ça on faisait
faire du sale à quelqu'un d'autre que
nous mêmes et puis maintenant on se
retrouve dans la main de la chine parce
que 95% des terres rares sont produites
en chine donc il ya pas mal de
dépendance comme ça qui sont créés et
qui sont autant créer quelque qu'il ya
un congrès il ya un congrès du parti
communiste à l'automne un grand congrès
très attendu est ce qu'on peut imaginer
une infection est ce que c'est jiping
tout puissant président à vie décide de
tout tout seul sans que personne ne
puisse infléchir quoi que ce soit abbas
esquissé ce qu'il a essayé de mettre en
place depuis depuis 2012 il a pris petit
à petit il est devenu le président de
tous on dit et non seulement il est
devenu le président de tous mais il a il
s'est arrangé pour que le le parti
redevienne le la base de tout est donc
donc donc il est il
contrôle absolument
tous les aspects tous les domaines il a
qu'il a créé des commissions et il est
le chef de toutes les commissions dans
tous les domaines donc en fait on peut
imaginer que sa stratégie c'est
d'essayer de contenir même si ça semble
extrêmement difficile
cette vague là
de printemps de refaire partir son
économie en croisant les doigts je n'ai
pas eu le temps de dire c'est que en
andorre de l'orgueil national
pour expliquer le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
acheté des vaccins étrangers c'est
qu'ils essayent d'en créer un eux-mêmes
arn messager le problème c'est que ça
marche pas problème c'est que ça marche
pas mais ça va peut-être finir par
marcher et donc je pense que maintenant
ils essaient il est là j'espère que
savoir la chine si on avance sur tous
les plans y compris scientifiques pour
pour conclure ce débat rapidement je
n'obtiens où je voudrais savoir est-ce
qu'on a un risque d'une nouvelle
épidémie parce que voilà c'est invariant
qu'on connaît bien nos micros nommé
scapa d'autres varions qui pourrait
arriver en chine voir d'autres virus et
qui pourraient nous revenir et là c'est
toute notre stratégie sanitaire qui
parce que autant d'un point de vue
économique d'un point de vue sanitaire
il faut pas souhaiter que la situation
se dégrade d'impôt l'humanité rend en
chine parce que effectivement
le gouvernement chinois contrôlent tout
sauf sauf ce qui est le plus petit le
virus
dont ils n'ont toujours pas trop bien
chercher l'origine non plus et la
roquette normalement oui mais elles
n'ont pas eu lieu ces enquêtes enfin non
c'est pas des enquêtes des sujets
qu'elle a lieu sept lots ils ont bloqué
un certain nombre de choses mais l'oréal
imaginons qu'ils aient une épidémie qui
dure plusieurs mois en chine parce
qu'ils essayent de la ralentir ils ont
intérêt à la ralentir
ça laisse du temps un au virus de se
renouveler de à nous de perdre notre
immunité donc de toute façon
on peut pas dire qu'on est sorti de
l'auberge nous aussi faut qu'on
surveille ce qui se passe mais
évidemment que après quelques mois sans
rien on n'est pas tout à fait sourire là
mais avec un niveau de transmission bas
on va redevenir susceptible l'histoire
n'est pas terminée par n'est pas terminé
bon alors on est en tout cas ce débat
s'achève je vous donnais le mot le mot
de la fin françoise nicolas oui sur le
sur la capacité de jean ping a changé
d'avis malgré tout on voit un tout petit
tout petit inflexions notamment sur
justement la mise au pas des des
entreprises de films tech ou de high
tech on a l'impression qu'un léger
rétropédalage avait donc peut-être
s'est-il rendu compte que c'était pas
nécessairement une très très bonne idée
de mettre au pas ces gens là qui ont
fait en grande partie la prospérité de
la chine les jack marié autres merci
merci beaucoup merci pour vos éclairages
c'est un dossier évidemment qu'on va
suivre ici et qu'on comprend évidemment
qu'il n'est pas qu'il n'est pas terminée
vous rester avec moi jean marc daniel
parce qu'on va parler à présent de la
situation économique en france on la
croyait définitivement derrière nous
revoilà donc l'inflation 4,8 pour cent
en avril elle pourrait atteindre 10%
dans les prochains mois le spectre de la
stagflation refait surface alors comment
l'endiguer on a plein de questions à
vous poser jean marc daniel comme les
skis ce sujet signe à nicolas quad ou
si on vous invite aujourd'hui jean marc
daniel c'est pour faire les cons ce
parler gros sous car partout les prix
augmentent l'essence la nourriture
l'électricité une inflation qui se
rapproche des 5% sur le mois d'avril et
un pouvoir d'achat en baisse ce serait
même la préoccupation principale des
français
une petite pension est on obligé de
faire très attention
c'est pas la même vie que simon a n'a
rien du tout moi avec ma petite retraite
avant je vivais je pouvais enfin
maintenance pour assurer mais avant
d'aborder toutes ces questions voici
votre s'élever jean marc daniel parmi
vos multiples casquettes vous êtes
économiste professeur émérite à le fcp
directeur de la revue sociétal vous avez
publié de nombreux ouvrages parmi
lesquels l'histoire de l'économie
mondiale ou encore il était une fois
l'argent magique et vous chronique est
régulièrement l'économie sur bfm
business les années soixante dix comme
la société était beaucoup moins
concurrentiel qui avait même on contrôle
les prix donc vous subissez une hausse
du prix du pétrole vous allez voir
l'autorité responsable de contrôle des
prix et vous dit écoutez il faut
répercuter sinon c'est matt smith à
l'inflation sujet majeur de la campagne
présidentielle et qui s'annonce déjà à
preignan dans les futures législatives
à chacun sa solution maintenant le
public très clairement il faut dé geler
le point d'indicé que l'état prenne à sa
charge une partie des cotisations
retraite qui sont sur les salaires mais
dans tout ce gloubiboulga nous on vous
avoue qu'on s'y perd un peu alors on
vous pose la question jean marc daniel
face à l'inflation vaut-il mieux bloquer
les prix ou augmenter les salaires la
parole est à vous
alors avant les soldes sur jean marc
daniel un petit point sur l'état des
lieux tous les conjoncturistes nous
explique la station va s'installer dans
le pays qu'elle va augmenter jusqu'où à
votre avis pour combien de temps alors
c'est en fait une question à laquelle il
est assez difficile de répondre pourquoi
parce que quand on regarde les principes
de l'économie notamment ceux qui sont
résumées il ya un économiste américain
qui s'appelle nicolas clé gorille men ku
qui a dit et des principes qui
structurent l'économie et une fois qu'on
a réfléchi à ces dix principes on est
capable de répondre à tous et donc sur
l'inflation il ya deux raisons pour
lesquelles il est normalement de
l'inflation la première raison c'est
quand le
l'état dépense beaucoup plus qu'ils ne
gagnent donc créer artificiellement des
revenus du pouvoir d'achat et donc il ya
trop de revenus en face de la production
et donc les entreprises sont incitées à
augmenter leurs prix pour absorber c'est
excès de demande on n'est pas dans ce
cas de figure n'est pas dans ce cas de
figure et puis la deuxième situation
c'est quand eux il ya effectivement une
boucle prix salaires qui se met en place
et les entreprises sont obligées pour
des raisons x ou y d'augmenter les
salaires ils répercutent s'assure sur
les prix on n'est pas non plus le nom de
figure ce sont les prélats
et l or donc les spécialistes il en fait
quand on regarde bien la définition vrai
de l'inflation celle qui est retenu dans
les manuels c'est une hausse durable et
générale des prix or elle n'est pas
générale la question c'est est-ce que
c'est durable ces terres est ce que
cette hausse des prix de l'énergie va 5
ces kystes et dans l'économie et va
finir par provoquer la hausse générale
qui serait véritablement de les frères
elle n'est pas général mais comment ça
va s'élargir sur beaucoup de produits
sains il suffit d'aller dans un
supermarché pour le constater elle
commence à s'élargir sur beaucoup de
produits alors quand on regarde
néanmoins à moyen terme là aussi la
réserve fédérale aimait beaucoup de
théorie c'est plutôt la banque
d'angleterre d'ailleurs qu'ils allaient
des théories les plus cohérents menez
fédéral à l'époque de ben bernanke qui
disait en fait l'inflation à l'erreur ce
serait de regarder sur une année où sur
deux ans il faut regarder sur la durée
d'un cycle économique grosso modo il
faut remonter à la période 2009 qui
était la dernière contraction brutale de
l'activité économique liée à des
paramètres économiques sont réels
puisque la récession de 2020 c'était la
pandémie qui était à l'origine de la
récession donc si on regarde ça et qu'on
regarde comment ont évolué les prix en
zone euro par exemple ça nous arrive à
dire que met en avant pour l'instant le
bse l'inflation moyenne a été de 9,3
pour cent c'est dire que la hausse des
prix actuelle d'une certaine façon en
partie qu'on pense des baisses de prix
qui ont été
les règles du jeu pendant quelques
années ce n'est pas si grave si je vous
entends bien vous avez entendu la phrase
de bruno le maire cette phrase qu'a
marqué les esprits le choc énergétique
que nous subissons 2022 comparable au
choc pétrolier de 1973 alors si vous
êtes d'accord avec ça alors ça je suis
assez d'accord avec ça
pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est qu'effectivement le prix du
pétrole augmente et la en proportion il
a moins augmenté que les progrès à
l'époque il prit avait été multiplié par
quatre là on est même si on regarde en
termes de pétrole de prix du pétrole le
baril de brent est allé jusqu'à 130 1
mais il est redescendu descendu et en
2008 il était monté jusqu'à serait à 45
dollars le baril bon et donc on a connu
des chocs pétroliers et déjà et ces
chocs pétroliers effectivement donc en
2008 après il ya eu 2009 2009 c'était la
crise financière mais c'était aussi une
ponction sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages qui était lié à l'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie donc on est dans un
choc pétrolier la comparaison avec des
années 70 peut-être pas les meilleurs
mais l'idée de choc pétrolier est tout à
fait pertinente le faire qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire parce que là on bloque les
prix gouvernement a commencé à le faire
avec des boucliers en tous genres sur le
gaz sur l'électricité où on augmente les
salaires oui alors derrière les salaires
il est bon la vie oui les salaires
augmentent assez naturellement puisque
le smic est indexé donc vous avez passé
sur l'inflation dont vous avez et
ensuite ça se répercute donc dans le
premier décile des salaires dans les
salaires les plus bas c'est pratiquement
l'équivalent de ce qui a été considéré
pour le pour le semis nom qui va y avoir
une revalorisation automatique qui va se
faire conques la tuer desmons au dessus
du smic est une sorte de vague qui
s'étend jus d'une onde qui montent comme
ça qu'on seront donc on considère contre
le deuxième est le 6ème dissidents qu'au
milieu 1% d'augmentation du smic ça
conduit à 0 2% d'augmentation des
salaires et puis après au delà c'est des
salles action plus élevé donc là on est
dans des situations s'inquiéter parce
qu'on nous dit attention spirale
inflationniste quand les prix augmentent
si les salaires suivent attention
stagflation la toux la croissance est
très basse et donc il pourrait y avoir
un effet d'emballement doux et c'est ma
question je suis béotienne 1 les taux
directeurs vient d'être augmentée par la
banque fédérale américaine ce soir de
0,5 point expliqué notre façon très
claire qu'est-ce que ça pour effet
pourquoi il faut le faire alors pourquoi
il faut le faire parce que les taux
d'intérêt étaient devenus dans certains
certaines périodes négatives il était
très bas et donc les taux d'intérêt
qu'ils sont faibles effectivement peut
considérer que ça favorise
l'investissement ça permet aux états de
s'endetter sans avoir des conséquences
très négatives sur leur politique
budgétaire mais symétriquement
l'épargnant elysées et symétriquement il
ya toute une partie des revenus de la
population qui sont les revenus liés à
lehman qui disparaissent et donc il ya
des taux d'intérêts déquilibre et donc
depuis six mois un an avant le choc lié
à la guerre en ukraine et avoir même les
histoires autour du pétrole
les banques centrales notamment sous
l'impulsion de la banque d'angleterre
avait dit on peut pas continuer à avoir
des taux d'intérêt aussi bas donc il
faut remonter les taux d'intérêt la
question c'est jusqu'où à quel moment il
va falloir s'arrêter pour l'instant on
est encore dans des zones qui sont des
zones qui sont conformes à ce que
normalement l'économie doit avoir comme
niveau donc si je comprends bien
augmenter les taux directeurs les taux
d'intérêt la bce s'apprête sans doute à
faire la même chose ça permet de piloter
finement les choses pour éviter cette
spirale inflationniste seulement et puis
surtout et alors il ya une conséquence
qu'on est et qu'on n'avait pas vu
précédemment notamment à l'époque des
chocs pétroliers et on est dans une
période où les changes sont libres le
taux de change vous ai voulu tout le
temps et donc si vous remontez pavot
taux d'intérêt votre devise notre bonne
et a plutôt tendance à se déprécier par
rapport au dollar en particulier et donc
on en revient à alain dont je parlais
tout à l'heure que pendant très
longtemps l'un d'eux s'est dit je laisse
effectivement mais taux d'intérêt très
bas ma devise c'est déprécier comme ça
je suis beaucoup plus compétitif je peux
vendre beaucoup mieux par rapport à ses
principaux concurrents par exemple la
chine et puis l'un d'eux vient de
remonter ses taux c'est dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya la réserve fédérale
des états unis mais il ya aussi la
banque centrale d'inde alors s'est passé
relativement inaperçu mais c'est quand
même une économie du g20 et c'est pas
une économie totalement négligé pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont en train de se dire si
on laisse la roupie filets par rapport
au dollar la facture pétrolière va
encore augmenter et on entend ce
discours en allemagne on dit écoutez la
bce devrait remonter c'est tout parce
que la baisse de l'euro est en train
d'alourdir la facture énergétique la
facture pétrolière grosso modo je
reprends 2008 en 2008 quand le dollar
quand le baril lever 145 dollars l'euro
valait 1,60 dollar donc on voyait pas
le choc sur le même ampleur aujourd'hui
où le baril est à 110 115 dollars mais
l'euro est un 0-5 voilà donc il ya aussi
cette idée que remonter les taux ça
permet aussi d'attirer des capitaux et
donc revaloriser la valeur de sa devise
pour la politique économique globale on
entend ici ou là des est-ce que c'est
des rustines on veut par exemple de la
grande distribution tient ça c'est
concernant pour les gens mais chelle
edouard leclerc qui annonce un bouclier
anti inflation sur un panier de 220
produits de première nécessité ça peut
marcher c'est intelligent quitte à
d'ailleurs augmenté les prix sur
d'autres produits sains oui oui poussé
ponctuelles ça c'est plutôt a été déjà
par rapport par le petit extrait là que
vous avez diffusé je racontais que dans
les années 60 70 effectivement il y
avait un contrôle des prix est la
conséquence est que la concurrence ne
jouais pas c'est dire que les
entreprises les chefs d'entreprise les
grands secteurs c'était pas forcément
comprise par entreprise mais les grands
secteurs économiques aller voir la
direction des prix etc écouter vous
pouvez pas nous laisser dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
laissez-nous à augmenter les prix là
maintenant la direction normalement la
direction générale les prix n'existe
plus il ya une direction de la
concurrence les prix sont libres depuis
1986 et donc michel edouard leclerc dit
moi je suis en situation de concurrence
je vais profiter de cette situation pour
gagner des parts de marché sur mes
principaux concurrents et le le
bénéficiaire ultime de la stratégie de
michel edouard leclerc c'est
effectivement le consommateur alors il
ya quand même un secteur sur lequel tout
ça ça joue pas c'est l'endroit où il
n'ya pas de concurrence et où on n'a
aucune prise sur la concurrence en
question c'est le secteur énergétique on
importe le pétrole mais alors justement
question est ma dernière question
pendant la campagne présidentielle on a
beaucoup entendu notamment à la gauche
de la gauche dire que cette crise
énergétique certes il ya un énorme choc
de demande posco vide et la guerre en
ukraine évidemment à l'accentuer mais
qu'il y avait aussi des spéculateurs qui
jouait notamment
de cette situation que ce soit le coc
vide où la guerre est ce qu'il ya des
profiteurs de crise dans ce moment là où
ils profitent d'ailleurs les pétroliers
pouvoir profiter ça et donc augmenter
leurs prix il peut y avoir mais ça reste
totalement marginal c'est les guides et
des accapareurs des profiteurs depuis la
plus haute antiquité dès qu'il ya un
problème de rupture d'approvisionnement
on accuse toujours des des profiteurs
des accapareurs d'être à l'origine de
tout ça en revanche ce que je trouve à
la fois intéressant et inquiétant d'une
certaine façon c'est que en
subventionnant le prix des carburants et
du gouvernement comme le gouvernement le
fait d'une part on subventionne des
importations alors que nous avons une
situation de déficit de notre commerce
extérieur qui est inquiétante donc on
favorise le creusement de ce déficit est
alors le gouvernement par exemple là
bien avant le fait que mario draghi en
italie faisait la même chose sauf que
l'italie est un excédent extérieur dans
qu'elle n'est pas exactement dans les
mêmes conditions et puis la deuxième
chose on a voulu augmenter la taxe
carbone pour nous assister être moins
consommateur de pétrole et l'or nous
subventionne quelques années a pris pour
consommer le pétrole en question donc il
ya une incohérence dans tout ça qui fait
que cette politique est une politique
qui ne peut pas durer éternellement
merci beaucoup c'était très clair on
voudrait invitera d'ailleurs parce que
la question de l'embargo sur le gaz
russe est sur le pétrole aura aussi des
conseils qu'on s'en doute sur sur les
prix et puis le jeu en avance à la chine
la chine également c'est pas fini non
plus j'aurais été avec moi jean marc
daniel c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soir
richard wehrli va nous parler de
l'europe sociale version mélenchon la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand va
décortiquer ce qui est un peu le mot de
la semaine radicalité et puis la météo
législatives désamour dingue amano a
franchi les voici
bonsoir à tous les trois ravi de vous
retrouver on va commencer par l'actu
chaude les législatives avec vous elsa
alors ce soir dans les 577 vous nous
parler bien sûr de l'accord la corsa y
ait officialisé entre le parti
socialiste et la france 1 somistes
exactement myriam ce matin on l'a su un
accord de principe était trouvée mais il
a fallu encore discuté chaque mot chaque
virgule avec antoine coutin biasi
mettions ces dons rendue dans le 10e
arrondissement de paris passage dubail
c'est le siège la france insoumise alors
les journalistes qui font le pied de
grue jour et nuit pour suivre toutes les
négociations entre les différentes
composantes de la gauche le lv c'était
bon le pcf aussi rester un gros morceau
le pc on est allé bas autour de 13
heures et on s'est dit tiens on a eu un
indice comme quoi c'était bientôt fini
jean luc mélenchon le leader des
insoumis était arrivé alors il a quand
même fallu attendre deux heures pour
voir apparaître la fumée blanche la
délégation ps le ps rejoint la nuque
baisse la nuque sont pas encore tout à
fait mis d'accord sur la prononciation
je crois la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale écoutez pierre
jouve et on l'a vu à l'image c'est le
porte parole et négociateur pour le ps
je crois que aujourd'hui nous sommes à
quelques heures d'un moment historique
d'un moment historique attendu depuis
des années par le peuple de gauche qui
nous demandaient qui nous demandaient
ardemment de savoir nous rassembler et
puis parmi les points de crispation on
en a beaucoup parlé c'était l'europe
notamment la question de la
désobéissance alors finalement dans le
communiqué ça donne désobéir pour les
interroger pour les autres une
formulation pour mettre finalement tout
le monde d'accord puisque de toute façon
l'objectif il est partagé écoute
emmanuel bompard c'est le négociateur
côté un sou mais cette fois notre
objectif commun c'est de faire en sorte
que si nous dirigeons ce pays dans
quelques semaines nous puissions tout
simplement appliquer le programme sur
lequel on a été élu et pour appliquer ce
programme il faut faire en sorte c'est
une obligation parce que ce programme
est peut être en contradiction avec un
certain nombre de règles ou de traités
européens il faut assumer l'idée que
parfois il faut ne pas respecter ou d
obéir à certaines de ses règles il reste
un détail mais il est de taille ce
détail c'est le conseil national qui
doit maintenant approuver cet accord
côté socialiste exactement convoqué
demain à 19 heures ça risque de tanguer
déjà on a entendu les éléphants qui pour
qui cet accord ne passe pas du tout du
tout certains ont déjà fait part de leur
désaccord pour françois hollande et bien
ils récusent cet accord jean christophe
cambadélis parle de signature de
reddition stéphane le foll lui les prêts
et bien mener la campagne des dissidents
bernard cazeneuve annonce ce soir qu'il
quitte le parti socialiste on l'était au
ps mais depuis il a fait le choix de
rejoindre la majorité cette fois ci on
parle de de manuel valls qui refait
parler de lui aux législatives
exactement l'annoncent dans la 5e
circonscription
de l'étranger celles qui courent tiens
tiens l'espagne et le portugal manuel
valls il a été premier nice vous l'avez
dit mais il avait rejoint la majorité il
avait été élu sous les couleurs avant de
quitter pour tenter son aventure en
espagne mais le député sortant stéphane
vosges et à bien il a la ferme intention
d'être candidat malgré tout côté siège
de campagne rappelle pour l'instant les
investitures elles sont pas officiels
ont les prévoyez hier c'est aujourd'hui
pardon ce sera finalement demain
dernière petite info oui dernières infos
de service public pour s'inscrire sur
les listes électorales vous avez jusqu'à
ce soir si vous êtes adepte du clavier
sur internet jusqu'au 6 par formulaire
papier météo complète des législatives
seigner elsa monde un gavage chaque soir
dans ça vous regarde on va enchaîner
avec vous richard vers l'est parce que
c'est à celje après l'accord ps
mélenchon vous voulez nous parler de
cette question de la désobéissance
civile prenez par les insoumis aux
traités européens sur l'europe sociale
vous nous dites ce soir attention
finalement dire qu'on ne peut pas
discuter des traités et bien ça peut
être un problème oui invoqué les traités
européens c'est toujours quelque chose
de très explosif en france parce que
d'abord ça ramène un souvenir qui est
souvent évoquée par la france a soumises
et par jean-luc mélenchon c'est celui du
référendum du 29 mai 2005
vous vous souvenez qu'à ce moment là le
projet de constitution européenne a été
rejeté par 54 6% des électeurs la
participation a été de 69 % c'est à dire
pas très loin des 71 % de la récente
élection présidentielle
c'est une équation absolument explosive
parce qu'au fond elle lance un
avertissement juridique un mot d'ordre
politique alors désolé ça veut dire au
fond à tout l'électorat vous ne pourrez
pas obtenir ce que vous voulez parce que
les traités européens sont irrévocables
ça c'est les opposants à jean luc
mélenchon qui le disent mais lui-même ou
ses soutiens en évoquant le
contournement de des traités européens
il n'arrange pas vraiment les choses
parce qu'il derrière ils font peur au
prince aux partenaires de la france
s'est notamment l'allemagne je rappelle
quand même que jean luc mélenchon dans
un livre publié en 2016 le hareng de
bismarck il a traité l'allemagne de
monstres dont le modèle est odieux c'est
vous dire que depuis l'accord signé par
les écologistes et les socialistes avec
lui ça fait quand même pas mal vibrer à
berlin où l'on s'inquiète allant ma
thèse est la suivante la question que
pose jean luc mélenchon elle est bonne
il y as besoin de mesures
d'accompagnement social dans un certain
nombre de pays parce que la situation le
sait au sein de l'union européenne elle
n'est pas identique tous les pays n'ont
pas les mêmes niveaux de salaires tous
les pays n'ont pas la même tradition de
service public ni même la même présence
géographique de ses services publics
mais sans arrêt ramener au traité ça
pose plus de problèmes que ça n'en
résout et je rappelle que par ailleurs
le traité de lisbonne qui a été approuvé
par le parlement français justement pour
contourner le fameux référendum est bien
dans son article 52 il crée une réunion
régulière d'un sommet social tripartite
et il affiche des objectifs de plein
emploi de progrès social et de cohésion
sociale ça devrait donc être possible de
faire avec ce traité alors vous nous
dites calmement nous sur ces questions
là sauf que quand même richard là à
bruxelles on s'inquiète et dans
certaines capitales européennes de voir
peut-être voilà les insoumis la gauche
de la gauche
enfoncé un coin voire peut-être prendre
la majorité à l'assemblée et prendrait
le chemin alors la france celui d'un
celui de l'apologue celui de la hongrie
sanctionné pour justement ne pas avoir
accepté oui ça c'est un peu la pire des
situations c'est comparer les
revendications sociales de la france a
soumises et jean luc mélenchon est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en pologne
hongrie parce que là franchement ça fait
complètement des libelles débat
politique ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
pologne et en hongrie c'est que le
système judiciaire est totalement aux
ordres du pouvoir politique c'est pour
ça qu'il y à une procédure d'infraction
qui a été lancée par bruxelles contre
ces deux pays mais on en n'est pas là
côté français je rappelle qu'il y a des
précédents en septembre 2020 le
gouvernement français a bel et bien
stopper la ratification de l'accord
commercial du mercosur je rappelle aussi
qu'en 2005 il y avait toute la polémique
autour de la directive bolkenstein doc
autrement dit oui posons la question de
revendications sociales et de la
nécessité d'une europe sociale mais
arrêtons de systématiquement d'un côté
ou de l'autre
s'en prendre aux traités européens parce
que le juridisme n'est jamais une bonne
réponse à la politique un petit
commentaire la cjue attentif
la différence entre la pologne et la
hongrie et nous c'est que nous on est
dans la zone euro alors que la pologne
la hongrie soit hors de la zone euro et
donc la sanction économique l'heure à
leur écart entre guillemets c'est la
dévaluation de leur monnaie et s'étaient
vite et d'ailleurs pendant très
longtemps la stratégie de la france ont
parlé pour la france de dirigisme
inflationnistes on me faisait
effectivement du social et à se mêler
beaucoup de choses et puis ont dévalué
sauf que maintenant on ne peut plus
dévaluer et donc à partir de ce
moment-là tout les problèmes que l'on va
rentrer rencontré sur le plan économique
ils vont se heurter au fait qu'il va
falloir aller chercher l'aide de nos
partenaires de la zone euro est le bon
exemple 7,6 presse on commence on fait
même voté son peuple en disant on ne se
soumettra pas et ça se termine par on
signe tout
alors l'itinéraire d'un mot avec vous
mariette darrigrand sémiologue ce mot
c'est celui de radical on a beaucoup
parlé de la droitisation dans la
campagne présidentielle et là depuis
l'élection on parle beaucoup de la
gauche on parle beaucoup et bien du
grand retour de jean-luc mélenchon oui
c'est ça et c'est une gauche radicale
effectivement ce petit mot est tout à
fait intéressant parce qu'effectivement
il a fait un voyage un peu un peu
curieux alors cette radicalité
finalement malgré toutes les différences
qui peut y avoir entre les divers partis
de gauche ils sont en train de parler
ensemble il ya un noyau qui pourrait
être ce qui les fédère c'est la
radicalité avec deux sujets c'est à dire
l'europe trop libérale selon eux et puis
aussi quand même le capitalisme mots de
mot honni de la tribu alors cette gauche
radicale est en train de s'élargir au
delà de la france insoumise tout se
passe comme si le radicalisme est une
nouvelle devenait une nouvelle opinion
pour vous c'est ça parce que notre vie
politique a besoin de nouveauté et donc
c'est la nouveauté du moment c'est la
tendance mais quand on regarde un peu
l'histoire de la notion voit au
contraire qu'elle est très ancienne le
radicalisme de gauche c'est peut-être
même le socle du progressisme à la
française si on repense un mets ton
affaire dreyfus et et loi sur la laïcité
en 1905 on est un peu à la base mais ce
qui se passe c'est que la notion c'est
complètement affadi au fil du temps et
puis on est les radicaux sont devenus
finalement contraire les modérés voire
des rad soc traiterait plan plan alors
ce qui se passe est pas la naissance
d'une notion mais plutôt sa renaissance
vintage dirait voilà c'est comme si on
recolorisées le film est d'ailleurs les
vieux films de renoir qui parle des gens
de peu comme disait l'historien pierre
sansot sens remarquable encore
aujourd'hui sont très regardé par les
jeunes j'ai pas à la règle du jeu la
fine équipe
germinal tous et les livres de nicolas
mathieu par exemple qui est un jeune
romancier reprennent cette idée de riom
co produit un seul grand succès ou annie
ernaux très mélenchonistes l heure il
redonne si vous vous laissez parler
oeuvre une esthétique très intéressante
balle à cette france dit d'en bas si
vous voulez mais ils le font dans un
registre qui font remarquer c'est à dire
qui mêle très bien la tradition et la
modernité c'est ça le vintage qui a
beaucoup de succès d'une façon générale
dans tous les compartiments de la
société et aussi que l'international
radical left alors oui bah voilà un
corps à la terre mais corps mais c'est
ça c'est aussi c'est exactement ça ce
que je veux dire c'est que le
radicalisme de gauche qui est en train
d'émerger n'est pas que franco-français
il se colorise on a parlé un peu de la
grèce qui était pas forcément la
meilleure expérience mais podemos en
espagne peut-être la gauche radicale
indigné c'est quelque chose et puis
effectivement là la gauche radicale qui
a été efficace dans si j'ose dire dans
le dans le bric sites en même temps il
fait peur un peu ce mot faut le
reconnaître elle a hérité mais alors ce
qui est adroit de la part des gens qui
utilisent ces signes et bien c'est
qu'ils font oublier les mots qui fâchent
ou les mots qui font peur précisément
comme prolétariat comme révolution alors
il y en a qui a échappé alors qu'il
pourrait faire peur c'est planification
écologique c'est comme un vraiment a
remarqué aux connotations au quasi
soviétique mais fait voilà mais il l'a
surpris par et belle macro et c'est ça
il a suivi notre président donc d'une
phase il y à une séduction de ses
références une séduction émotionnel
parce que je crois elle recrée un
collectif de gauche qui s'était quand
même assez perdu aux origines du mot
mariette que veut dire voilà c'est ça
qui m'intéresse est dedans parce que les
jeunes si vous voulez ce ne devrait pas
avoir la nostalgie des années programme
commun c'est quand même un peu que mais
ils l'ont peut-être parce que ça a sauté
une génération c'est mon hypothèse est
parce que ce mot il a une dynamique de
retour en quelque sorte parce que c'est
quoi radical bas c'est la racine donc
tout racine est originelle tout racines
n'aurait ancre dans quelque chose mais
son identité dans ce mot radical on y
arrive à gérer or mme d'identité et une
forme des sourds aux arts puisque ce
sont quand même des racines que naissent
les jeunes pousses mais est-ce que c'est
là dessus que je final ce jour c'est
intéressant sur le plan politique c'est
que le mot au lieu de dire extrémisme il
dit aujourd'hui authenticité autrement
dit lorsqu'on est radical ça veut pas
dire qu'on est voilà révolutionnaire
mais qu'on est vrai qu'on est vraiment
de gauche assuré non merci infiniment
mariette les évolutions d'un mot là le
sens évolué ça n'est plus ça ne fait
plus peur au fond c'était c'était très
intéressant merci beaucoup merci jean
marc daniel d'être venu sur le plateau
des cp merci à tous mes a franchi c'est
la fin de cette émission vous pouvez la
voir où la revoir sur la chaîne youtube
des cp tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire avec un film qui fait
partie de la série des mensonges de
l'histoire ce soir 1997 le scandale de
l'amiante signé eve minault très belle
soirée et à demain
[Musique]